[Music]
with Avengers infinity war less than one
month away and new trailers and footage
coming out almost daily it's getting
really hard to be patient and contain
our excitement but with it coming out so
soon I thought I'd take a couple videos
to talk about the villains that will be
seen in avengers' infinity war in this
video we'll be talking about the Black
Order
Thanos his personal team that does his
dirty work for him
before we get started I bet you won't
hit that little red subscribe button do
it so to start off the MCU actually
isn't calling this team of super
villains the Black Order they're calling
them the children of Thanos the story
and reasoning behind this can be
explained in the first guardians of the
galaxy movie where Gamora says that
Thanos is not her real father
Thanos actually killed her parents and
kind of kidnapped slash adopted her and
then raised her and nebula to be
ultimate fighting machines to do his
will the black order is relatively new
to Marvel Comics making their first
appearance only five years ago in 2013
so not much is known about each
individual members personal backstory
but I think it's safe to assume that
their stories will be somewhat similar
to Gamora and nebulous there's also a
member of the Black Order that will not
be in the MCU and that is supergiant so
she's not going to be in the movies
we're not gonna talk about her today
one particular assignment that Thanos
gives the Black Order and the comics is
finding the infinity gems or what we
call the Infinity stones in the MCU each
member of the Black Order is assigned an
Avenger who is holding an infinity stone
to go defeat and retrieve the stone from
it seems that the storyline in the MCU
might not be too far off from the comic
version as we have trailers that show us
Corvus glaive and Proxima midnight
trying to get the mind stone from vision
and ebony mah trying to get the time
stone from Doctor Strange so now that we
know what the Black Order is all about
let's talk about each of its individual
members first is Corvus glaive who is
the leader of the Black Order and Thanos
his right-hand man
Corvus is cruel arrogant and a warrior
who betrayed his own people and sold his
soul to Thanos Corvis has superhuman
strength
speed stamina durability and is a master
at combat and tactical abilities which
is why Thanos chosen to lead the Black
Order if those weren't enough Corvus is
immortal his immortality comes from his
weapon of choice his glaive if his
glaive stays in one piece Corvus cannot
die he can survive anything including
being obliterated the glaive can also
split atoms and can cut through any
known thing or person including the hulk
skin and stabbing the blade right
through Wolverines body assuming this
ability remains the same for him in
Avengers infinity war the Avengers are
going to have to find some way to break
his glaive if they want to kill him for
good not only are they going to have to
defeat him
they'll have to defeat his wife as well
Proxima midnight who was another member
of the Black Order Proxima midnight is
the most skilled fighter of the Black
Order this is mostly due to her super
strength speed and combatant abilities
and then it's also partly due to the
spear that she wields her spear which
was forged for her by Thanos was created
from a son trapped in a distorted
space-time acting and operating as a
star supernova and black hole at once
when she throws it it can turn into
multi arcing black energy beams carrying
tremendous mass and also she never
misses when she throws it she can also
throw the spear and have the black
energy turn into Nets weighing down an
immobilizing the target with the weight
of a Sun and last but not least the
spear contains a lethal toxin in it
which one comes in contact can kill just
about anything who see this power
demonstrated in the comics when she
binds the hulk with her spear and when
it comes in contact with him he reverts
back to Bruce Banner I'm not sure what
I'll will transfer over from the comics
to the MCU scene as Captain America and
the trailers catches a never missing
spear but the Avengers will certainly
have their hands full with Proxima
midnight next in the black order is
perhaps the most dangerous member a
Benina ma isn't so much a physical
fighter although he does have a
teleportation device and a device that
puts a force field around him but MA
actually prefers to stay away from the
physical fighting his real powers which
make him so dangerous are the fact that
he's a super genius and basically has
supernatural persuasive abilities with
just his words he is able to take a hold
of a person's thought process
make them serve his own will in the
comics he's able to overcome even the
most strongest minds such as dr. strange
making him summon Shuma gorath and to
the universe to cause destruction for
ebony MA it seems like his powers and
abilities are going to be transferred
over to his character in the MCU we seen
the trailers that have been released
evany ma captures dr. strange and works
his silver tongue on him who knows maybe
even shuma Gareth will make an
appearance the last of the Black Order
is the biggest and is the brother of
Corvus glaive the black dwarf in the
movie they're actually calling the black
dwarf Cole obsidian which is interesting
because in the comics the black order
themselves is actually referred to as
the Cole obsidian the black dwarf is the
powerhouse of the Black Order he's
basically their Hulk he is ridiculously
strong wields a two bladed axe and his
skin is unpenetrated the comics Thanos
sends him to Wakanda so it's most likely
that he's leading the attack that we see
on what Conda and the trailers and we
can most likely guess that there's gonna
be a pretty awesome fight scene between
him and the Hulk so this is everything
you need to know about the black order
and its members what do you guys think
of Thanos his own personal Avengers let
me know what you guys think about the
Black Order and how powerful they're
going to be going up against the
Avengers by leaving a comment below drop
a like don't forget to follow us on
Twitter and subscribe to our Channel
don't be like Doug another day that's a
Doug
you
[Applause]